en pleine étreinte avec sa
collaboratrice
le ministre de la santé
danic se retrouve au coeur d'un scandale
d'état matt ngoc 42 ans marié et père de
trois enfants est donc un fidèle les
chefs de partis et les présidents
sortants se sont aussi acquittés de leur
devoir ce matin vous voyez à l'écran
marine le pen pour le rassemblement
national jean luc mélenchon pour la
france est soumise mais aussi valérie
pécresse pour la droite la raison pour
laquelle ma tancock doit démissionner
n'a rien à voir avec sa vie privée mais
avec le fait qu'il est temps ministre de
la santé déplorable car la scène se
déroule en mai dernier et à cette
période les règles sanitaires énoncées
par le ministre lui-même sont très
strictes au royaume uni voyez le chiffre
de la participation à midi à 12,66 %
selon le ministère de l'intérieur contre
12,22 % à la même heure dimanche dernier
je comprends les énormes sacrifices que
vous avez tous fait pendant cette
pandémie et ceux qui décident des règles
sanitaires dans le pays doivent les
appliquer c'est pourquoi je dois
démissionner tout comme son adversaire
thierry mariani qui a voté un peu avant
midi à avignon
l'estimation de participation réalisée
par harris interactive pour m6 et vous
le voyez l es2 35,7 pour cent si nous ne
prenons pas les mesures qui sont
attendus la reconnaissance du vote blanc
le droit au référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et au référendum révocatoire
la fin de la monarchie présidentielle
bref la 6ème république aux alentours de
16 heures
des détonations retentissent au jardin
d'eole cette habitante filmé la scène
des consommateurs de crack sont visées
par plusieurs tirs de mortier il est 20
heures et une autre première estimation
vous le voyez la victoire la large
victoire en paca de renaud muselier 56
8%
il devance très largement le candidat du
rassemblement national thierry mariani
très soulagé le président sortant parce
que les scores sont plus larges que
prévu il pensait renaud muselier veux ni
retard ici s'exprimer il pensait que ce
serait serré
toute la soirée finalement il vient
assez tôt ici la progression très
importante entre les deux tours en paca
qui reste tout de même insuffisante pour
offrir la victoire démontre que la
mobilisation est la clé des victoires à
venir
et là aussi xavier bertrand l'emportent
52 9% des suffrages pour le président
sortant score assez large devant
sébastien chenu du rn 5 25 7%
ce chemin de l'espoir il démarre
maintenant
il démarre ici bible et hot france vive
la république et vive la france
nous allons écouter le candidat de la
république en marche dans la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
c'est laurent wauquiez on a des
défenseurs toute alerte qu'est-ce que
julien des républicains ici même erreur
j'ai un tropisme et voilà laurent
wauquiez là encore victoire large du
candidat ait l'air laurent wauquiez 55
9% fritz était pour vous un homme japon
écoutons le rang d'objet oui tous mûri
et c'est ce qui est harmonie gerra
damien qui fait plutôt bien évidemment
beaucoup d'émotion pour toute notre
équipe
le philosophe lisant de fragonard mise à
prix à 1,2 million d'euros est adjugée à
6,3 millions ces cinq fois la valeur
estimée et l'acheteur je peux vous
l'annoncer puisque j'ai le droit de vous
le dire c'est un acheteur français de la
chute d'une partie du peloton regarde
plutôt à gauche
vous l'avez vu sur votre écran une
spectatrice qui voulait montrer sa
pancarte à la télévision et bien n'a pas
vu arriver le peloton qui arrivait
derrière elle et le peloton a du coup
chuté derrière ce philosophe lisant
l'oeuvre du français j'en aurai
fragonard retrouver presque par hasard
en janvier lors de l'inventaire d'une
demeure bourgeoise de champagne elle
avait disparu il y a plus de 200 ans